ich bin da an einer casting nötig dass
woche noch einmal job sondern auf suche
noch ein glück der reporter spezial
herzlich willkommen das heißt ihre
schöne menschen oder die sind aktiv die
sind erfolgreich es fällt ihnen viele
spitzel nebenflüsse macht schönheit
wirklich glücklich und antwort die ich
während ich zusammen mit meiner musik
zum teil extrem mit ihrer musik und
ihrem körper beschäftigen
[Musik]
wir sehen die der modelagentur scout in
zürich da ich mir ständig auf der suche
nach neuen gesichtern junge frauen und
männer aus der ganzen schweiz hoffnung
dass sie völlig okay für gucci oder
calvin klein auf dem laufsteg stellt als
erstes wird projekt oftmals stimmen
ich bin
bayer schaffte mit modelvertrag
wir sind 13 hinter mir eigentlich
schöner macht die schönheit war findest
du was zum ganz einfach sagen change
tanja schmidt strahl ich will hier sehr
positiv ausstrahlen kann und ich finde
meine mensch im allgemeinen ist durch
strahlend schön macht will ich find
jeder mensch ist wunderschön sind ja
genau und wie immer aber das stimmt
nicht so wie also ich meine ich ein auto
stark hilft und der chance
es stimmt also schön im einstelligen zum
beispiel große und sie mit dem sie ja da
schreibt der standard zeigt jetzt aber
ich finde ich starte ich mit ihm einig
bist du immer mit dem das gros
ich lebe mini gresse wenn sie einen
festen halt nicht dann bin ich hatte
gehen auch im ganzen club
nötig sind eine klassische schönheit zu
machen oder um die ohren
sein stuhl selber der stadt speziell
jetzt habe ich es ist sehr speziell für
mich ist früher nicht wenige behaupten
früher bin ich halt meistens motto
begleitet wurde und der charakter an
jeglichem und jetzt lebe ich möchte
winkel ja also ich fotografiere jetzt
erst mal dein gesicht schaut mich ganz
gerade an bediener schäfer ist chefin
von der agentur ehemalige model
entscheid sei mit ihrem team mitwählen
gesichts mit wellen körper probiert eine
internationale modelkarriere zu
lancieren
wer es nicht schafft und vielleicht
immerhin kartei für werbekunden für
sogenannte commercial ja er hat einfach
es gibt so ganz typische gesichter wo
ich darauf liege und das ist jetzt der
leon
er hat zu dieser diese breiten
wangenknochen die sind diesen knutsch
roten mund wenn sie nicht fotogen ist
also da er kann sich jetzt wirklich
hinstellen wie er wählen
er ist einfach foto gehen und er hat so
dieses typische kampagnen gesicht jetzt
könnt ihr schnell de león vielmehr will
es nicht wenn du jetzt macht man also
ist also letztlich so also es wagt eine
show glücklich dass wenn wir es nicht so
oft
also vor allem in der vergangenheit
haben das durch netto immer kompliment
über sondern schöne augen nicht
im april hat wieso das muss das muss man
vorher selber nicht aber die busse aber
das tempo stimmt der vorwurf das
meerestier muss können das
schönheitsideal das wird für seine
models vor bestimmt nämlich gar nicht so
im alltag wert liegt jetzt der lehre
fertig macht wenn die jungs haben sie
uns etwas wer bestimmt denn das wir
schön findet ich glaube schon die große
masse
das heißt aber nicht also sicher so
diese diese gesichter wo wir jetzt an
bord sehr schön oder bor ist die schuld
das sind die gesichter die nicht fotogen
sind die sind hat schön und wenn man sie
fotografierten sehen eigentlich relativ
langweilig aus weil die sehr harmonisch
sind im gesicht da es passt alles
zueinander aber sobald du eben zu große
lippen hast oder rote haare oder zu
viele ferkel oder ein breites gesicht
deshalb so nicht so schön wirkt aber das
ist dass das vorgehen ist fotogen i tät
und schönsein das sind zwei paar
verschiedene schuhe
egal ob fotogen oder schön völlig aus
dem rahmen vor der schönheits norm jung
und schlankheit dort niemand forscher
zeigen es gibt das menschliche
schönheitsempfinden für symmetrie aber
im wesentlichen wird schönheitsideal für
die gesellschaft gemacht wie fest prägt
die eigene oberfläche dieses leben das
wetter von glücksforscher mathias
binswanger wissen zur landläufig heißt
sie wahre schönheit kommt von innen wenn
sie studien bestimmt enormen stellenwert
heutige gesellschaft und dem saarland
keine innere schönheit das sind andere
wert die spiele dauern aber noch an
ein mangel an äußerer schönheit mit
innerer schönheit kompensieren also
schönheit ist extrem wichtig
war es für die kleinen ist mir zum
beispiel bezüglich glück also durch
manager woche sind da der mittwoch ein
unglaubliches glück können sie ja
gesehen was in der heutigen gesellschaft
ein hoher stellenwert hat und sie sind
dann plötzlich begehrt sind möglichkeit
aber andere nennt das heißt die
natürlich zum teil schon mit relativ
wenig aufwand den sie ja viel erreichen
das gibt dann auch selbstbewusst sieht
das kritisch aber auch toll aber geht
natürlich heiß problem schönheit ist
vergänglich
oder es ist dann irgendwann wieder weg
die schönheit und den makro natürlich
schon gerne zwei oakley tamino person
armenische in haid und auch von
interessieren was auch den immer so
verein also mit dem monaten lebe macht
schönheit erfolgreich
ja da gibt es auch dazu dass die
menschen wo sie sind auch mehr erfolg
and dass man die auf ungezählte andere
menschen nicht so schön sind und dass
sich das auf dem grund eines zahlt
[Musik]
qsc ist also das kapital hätten
unumstrittene wert unserer
leistungsgesellschaft wir sind zurück im
casting ihrer modelagentur scout in
zürich die 72 jährige katharina und
sankt anna ist eine von neun junge liegt
wo sich die hoffnung gemacht mit ihre
musik geld zu dienen hat die chance kam
dank von der fahrschule dracula nicht
auszumachen die allgemeine level mit
darf noch einmal zum abschluss studiums
kurzgeführt komischen vertrag überfällig
und wenn das nicht klappt ich mache
weiter bis das irgendwo mehr drauf macht
ist das nicht immerhin müsste ich dir
doch besucher endlich funktioniert ich
finde es halt einfach auf initiative
unserer machen jetzt macht und einfach
daran glaube dass das schon jeder noch
zwei stunden dies probe shooting für die
kandidatinnen und kandidaten werden
entlang
y y ich im moment entschädigte wie sie
[Musik]
mich für die jetzt noch mal die mit den
abstehenden ohren interessieren also die
die wird auf jeden fall kein klassisches
modell das gesicht so viel total cool so
hübsch hässlich ist sie aber einiges
gemacht worden erlaubt wurde traf sich
das ja wie passt das system dass ihr
sagt sie stolz
aber die gesellschaft sagt nein die
machen musst du spürst das andere ist
aber genauso toll mein körper die man
reisepass gibt mehrere sieht der mensch
ist so unterschiedlich dass ein größerer
breite schmaler persönlichkeiten hinter
machte den ausdruck komplett nur schöne
fassaden rangnick das ist wunderschön
also sodann haustieren die noch mal
zurück dass ich so er war da kann es
jetzt gut drüber schreiben somit das
vielleicht liegt ja
ich würde den leon mal gerne anschauen
möchte so machen da ist ja noch sehr
jung aber das sieht man zum beispiel
hier hatten unglaublich fotogen ins
gesicht da auch zehn jetzt verstanden
dass da habe ich ja das gemüse auf der
erste blick durch die modellierte foto
gehen also eigentlich unser thema du
hast jetzt ziemlich ein sehr attraktives
gesicht wunderschöne augen und wer
ansprechen
das macht nichts
kathrin also sie ist jetzt eigentlich so
also sie ist eigentlich so ein typischer
klassische modell aber das brauchen wir
auch gut gestellt jetzt würde ich gerne
noch mal sind doch was ist jetzt also
der hund ja er wird die wird gebucht und
rasierten viel eintritt
insgesamt dass man auch schon sicher
sind unter vertrag
also unter vertrag model mäßig würde ich
sagen wir ganz definitiv 2 und 2 3 für
commercial würde ich sagen wo wir sagen
doch werbemäßig knallhartes business
kommentiert oder das also da wird bb ein
exit bearishes und dann berichts breit
und die sieht stimme proportionen also
sehr menschenfreundlich sein sprich
nicht unter verschluss
dazu braucht es gut und recht ja aber
wenn ein bürojob selbstbewusste darauf
knallhart das duo gutem timing bist oder
oder wenn ein mediziner bist dann musst
du auch dementsprechend wirst du nur
beurteilt was
die gut bist oder wände und europe ist
also das ist ja in jeder branche so
machen liegt schönheit glücklich dem
leibe wie weiblich aber ich glaube es
hat auch damit zu tun dass ich so lange
damit konfrontiert bin natürlich fand
ich das auch als ich angefangen zu model
argyle und so aber wenn du wenn du drin
bist dann dann dann siehst du die
schönheit nicht mehr
das ist genauso wenn du wenn du jetzt
meine freundin bis dann sehe ich deine
schönen augen vielleicht irgendwann noch
nicht mehr dann ist es dass dann der
inneren werte die nicht interessieren
und deswegen sehe ich das nicht mehr
der angriff immer bedienen wir sind sehr
gespannt wie es mit deiner junge frauen
und männer vita gar keine klaren trend
scouts wieder mit menschen die ganz
sieht dann griff ihres äußere
angesprochen werden aber im gegensatz zu
denen da nicht unbedingt positiv
menschen über dem schönheitsideal von
schlanker körper wird entsprechend und
was alexandra baumann beim training mit
ihrem personal coach des schlafs
geschäfte und dem zahn ist das heißt
wenn ich mir sicher bin ich fahren sie
langsam aufruf was aber das mittlerweile
so clever dass die relativ schnell sei
aber dass je nach umfang der einigkeit
herrscht um meiner seite sicher fixiert
und alexander seit sie sich in einem ach
ja
dass es kontakte löschen und machen
alles freiwillig die 41 jährige kämpft
mit übergewicht
seit kurzem ist sie erstmals
zuversichtlich dass ihr jahrelanges
leiden unter dem körpergewicht ein ende
haben könnte
dank einen magenbypass operation
in erster linie bedeutet freiheit wo
nicht mehr jetzt langsam zurückerobern
nachdem ich mich sehr lang im körper
gefangen gefühlt haben wenn genau
diejenige oder eine variation von einem
jahr mit dem man mit frauchen der
skywalk macht ist ein anderes wie
geplant bis grundwasser lüttich ist
sogar noch legen um damit die hand
den eigenen körper als unendlich schwere
last empfinden und ihn ablehnen
dieses gefühl entwickelte sich bei
alexander baumann schon sehr früh
bereits als mädchen wurde sie auf ihr
gewicht reduziert
[Musik]
wenn ich meine kinder vor dem new yorker
und verglichen mit der anderen kinder
wurden von den ruf sind eigentlich
nichts gefühl ich sei schon so schaurig
fällt schwer aber ich weiß das genau
sollte sich die erste haben angefangen
hat wo man mir dort wo sich nachdem es
erstmal ein nachbar gesagt du bist eine
richtig große gefällt die tun kann ich
mich noch an ihm selber können
an der schwarzen elster es eigentlich
wirklich um in die kindheit meine jugend
mini mini für eine erwachsene yards
erinnere
weil im moment hat es gebe nichts schön
gefühlt habe ich drei oder vier wo man
also spontan wieder in seine zelle wie
viel musik abstoßend da hätte man hund
die zur auswahl wo man aufzählen könnte
[Musik]
negative emotionen habe sie jeweils mit
essen runtergeschluckt sagt baumann
sie wurde zur frust esserin mittlerweile
ist sie mehr als 30 kilo leichter doch
trotzdem übergewichtig die gesellschaft
lässt sie das gnadenlos spüren dass sie
mich sehr oft dicke in spießrutenlauf
werden
felix gefühl haben oder oft will
contador nicht grün weiß nicht ob es
gesund sich auf das gesunde essen im
restaurant dann ist es sehr häufig hört
ja ja klar jetzt zehn salat aber warum
ist sie die haar sitzt ein jockey und so
weil ich hab's und sich beispielsweise
ich mir kurz nach der mager
bypass-operation mal passiert das
protein pudding gekauft habe war dass
mir ein älterer herr hat mich so
angelegt so bewies aber und derartige
funde frist doch noch putting the
mission of ersten mal wird sie
hoffentlich hat jedem fall wirklich
nicht gesehen ich muss zwar nicht in die
berge so wichtig sie für die anders
erklären da bin ich so stockwerk sie
waren nämlich auch eine sage ja und ich
finde wie männer es ist es ist ja noch
mal anders einmal so gemütlich und ja
man ist auch nochmal anstoßen gefühl die
extrem gesellschaft das ist doch die
schlacht ist variante vor dem wo man sie
kann ja
[Musik]
gut drin maz 69 jahre alt auch sie hat
eine marken bypassoperation hinter sich
das übermäßige essen bekam sie nie in
den griff sie nach ca die namenlose
sucht die zunge und sind friede
also ich konnte sie dann der schlüssiger
die ganze blöcke mit dürrenmatt ist
künstlerin und die jüngste tochter des
schriftstellers friedrich dürrenmatt ihr
aussehen insbesondere ihr gewicht seien
immer thema gewesen in ihrem leben auch
in der familie
[Musik]
wenn wir jetzt der vater ed doud rambo
und mir zehn hunde lebten aber weniger
halt findet diese gebiete schön die
bismarck frau kritisierte will sich
lieber prinzip was ich dir mit dem raum
zur hälfte über mich als ich auf einem
jahr gelang kloten wundertüte dass sich
nicht die schönste frau b aber eines
tages gar nicht merkt dass der sieg ist
dass ich mich was gesellschaft dankt sie
ist fertig punkt
mit ihrem aussehen sei sie während
jahren angelegt habe als gelernte
opernsänger den immer wieder bühnen jobs
nicht erhalten mit der begründung ihre
figur sei unpassend
schließlich verabschiedete sich
dürrenmatt vom zwang äußeren schönheits
kriterien genügend zu müssen
[Musik]
sie ließ sich zur illustration und
grafiker den umschulen
die augen geöffnet puncto schönheit habe
ihr ein schicksalsschlag
dadurch schwindet zweiter vater
begleitet dort und für mich ist
wunderschön sie bis zuletzt den hätte
schönheit kreißsäle von ixia das ist
einzigartig sie und das ist wahrlich
schon hält sie mit der mauer konnte ihre
es gibt wunderschöne schachtel und
präsentiert die schachtel und den es
wunderbare chance durch die schachtel
oder dax etr sowie witze vorverpackte
oder den entschuldigung über 60 kilo
leichter ist seit ihrer operation
schönheit war kein beweggrund für den
eingriff von einem schlanken körper
träumt sie schon lange nicht mehr
das glück sondern im moment besser
laufen
vielen dank dankbarkeit wichtig für mich
hoch am morgen stieg machen und ich bin
glücklich darüber sie darf jetzt
schraube das kann ich für sehr lang
nicht so vertraut
alexandra baumann auf den weg zu einem
arzttermin stark übergewichtige adipöse
menschen wie sie die während langer zeit
erfolglos versucht haben ihr gewicht zu
reduzieren gelten offiziell als krank
sie haben versucht ihr bmi liegt weit
über dem von normalgewichtigen
viele sind sozial isoliert fühlen sich
die wenigsten von ihnen trotzdem
versucht verliest er chirurg marco peter
im zusammenhang mit einer magenbypass
operation die schönheits diskussion
möglichst zu vermeiden wenn er stellt
fest die meinung sei hartnäckig
verbreitet dass es sich bei krankhaftem
übergewicht nicht um ein
gesundheitsproblem sondern um einen
selbstverschuldeten schönheitsfehler
handle
wir versuchen patienten gesünder zu
machen im alltag funktioneller zu machen
und das ist auch etwas was wir unseren
kollegen und vielen zuweisern immer
wieder erklären müssen den skeptikern
dass es nicht darum geht jemanden
schöner zu machen
dünner zu machen sondern es geht nur
darum ihn gesünder zu machen und daran
lasse ich mich auch messen was ist mit
den begleiterkrankungen blutzucker
bluthochdruck was ist mit der
lebensqualität was ist mit der mutter
die plötzlich nach dem gewichtsverlust
wieder mit den kindern spielen kann das
sind aspekte die mir wichtig sind aber
keine kosmetischen aspekte und die
stehen bei dieser operation auch nicht
im vordergrund
täter stellt bei seiner arbeit immer
wieder fest dass hausärzte patienten
nicht zu weisen obwohl die kriterien für
eine operation erfüllt sind
er spricht von diskriminierung dass die
kollegen das nicht zuweisen kann zwei
gründe haben entweder kennen sie die
daten einfach nicht bzw
erkennen sie sie nicht anders kann ja
sein oder sie haben ein emotionales
problem damit die patienten zuzuweisen
weil sie immer noch davon ausgehen dass
adipositas keine erkrankung ist sondern
ein mehr oder weniger selbst bestimmen
bares schicksal das man mit ein bisschen
sport und ein bisschen die hält und ein
bisschen selbstdisziplin ganz leicht in
den griff bekommt und das ist falsch
diese daten gibt es einfach nicht also
wer das glaubt der hat zehn 15 jahre
medizinische wissenschaftliche
entwicklung schlichtweg verpennt
diskriminierung gegen dicke ist das
gesellschaftlich einfach so akzeptiert
weil landläufig gilt dicksein ist
hässlich und selbst verschuldet
alexander baumann hält dagegen und zeigt
sich nicht schlank will sie werden
sondern akzeptiert wie sie ist ist mir
eigentlich sehr wichtig freie plattform
apps instagram aufnahmen und perfekte
körper zeigen bewohner in arbeit ist
zeigen und so einfach dem schema
wasserstoff der plattform und praxis
nicht entspricht es extrem wichtig
authentisch zu bleiben
mit allem was dazugehört und das sind
dann eigentlich auch eine unternehmung
amt
[Musik]
alexander baumann ist jetzt dhabi mia
und alexander baumann irak ch vieles von
dem was ich der körper ehrlich gesagt
dass mir wäre so krass sind liegt also
hält noch ihre muse beurteilen
ja sicher letztlich deutlich man ist
sich zeit
das ist nur gut sein dass ich gehöre ja
ich denke es wird ja jeden tag wo nicht
klappen und also jeden tag ohne job
klappt und einfach in eine schublade
gesteckt hatten nämlich schon so wirst
du sagen dass die scheibe unglücklich
gemacht
ich weiß nicht unglücklich der richtige
ausdruck ist es nicht einfach mehr
leisten als andere das nicht akzeptieren
aber natürlich hat auch wenige momente
wo es nicht dann unglücklich gemacht
habt was ich es denn was man vielleicht
oder email charity finnen projiziert wie
find ich glaube es ist zum großen teil
der schuldfrage also materieller
gesellschaft der schuld zurückgewiesen
um übergewicht
und es ist disziplin frage also im juni
wird die nicht projiziert dass ich
christ die pläne das kein wähler haben
dass ich mir gemerkt haben dass
möglicherweise weitere marken für
ausländische produktionen einfacher
wahrgenommen aber war so sieht es die
zahlen dieses neue was wir alles schon
passiert ist und was ich schon alles
probiert haben
ich glaube das wird auch sehr viele
weder verstanden auch würdigen und es
wird ein nachgefragt so eine schublade
beruf willenlose mensch macht der sport
rock der ganztag von fernseh und ist und
was ist der grund sie das nicht schafft
zum atmen haben nicht dass es einen
grund gibt warum es nicht geschafft
haben es immer wieder probiert ganz
verschiedene mit ganz verschiedenen aus
kann aber immer wieder abgenommen haben
einfach nicht könne wollte
denn nicht ganz perfekt aber
zurückgegangen ist ja um die kollegen
waren einfach mehr anerkenne dass es ist
für mich persönlich ich für mich ist der
suchterkrankung qantas sucht das ist
immer noch da und das ist es wohl nie
merken sie auch von den schienen oder
schaffen wir jetzt nicht plötzlich
glücklich und wie du jetzt 50 kilo
abgenommen wird einfach aber so die sage
mal dämon erworben hat oder ihr
psychischer probleme die soziale
isolation oder deren einsamkeit gefühl
oder was auch immer sind es sind so
viele für mich zum essen braucht und man
positive gefühl
diese nehmen und genau und glaubt
aufgabe schwierigen umgang mit einem
gefühl zu lernen und was ich schon immer
haben sehr stark ist blinker ich war
schon ganz also ich kann alle prüfungen
immer geschafft meine tipps volk machen
noch nichts tun und im überblick
das einfach nicht gegangen und ich
glaube dass ich so 1000 reagiert wenn
ein kopftor probierte sogar einig was
ich alles probiert und auch das ist ein
echter leidensdruck ich will halt
übergriffs augenfällig ist nicht
verstecken
doch alles nicht so an es gibt andere
sucht der franke der vorstudie hat die
sportfunktionäre märkten besonders
schönes gefühl wenn man so von dem
schönheitsideal redet menschen
übergewichtig sind schon mit dir herd
und werde härter kritisiert als
vielleicht wo ich weiß es nicht das
perfekte sicherheit oder irgendwer
pigmentstörungen oder so also reagiert
man auf menschen mit übergewicht
anderswo was wirklich körperlich oder
das muss aufhören
dicke sind und fragt und ich sage es
stimmt genauso wenig wie das irgendwie
zusammenbringen und ich denke das ist
doch lustig aber das muss aber nicht so
sein für das wird hart mit dem
übergewichtigen ist nicht bange
durch zeit mir sind sehr fest der
oberfläche inspiriert beeinflusst recht
oberflächlich gesellschaft das stimmt
aber interessant ist dass bei mir vor
schönheit redet und denke mir immer
aussehen aber es gibt menschen wenn man
mit einer schönheit retten
besonders
[Applaus]
da sitzt herzlich willkommen
bauer sieht für stück in szene und darum
schönheit effektiv ganz andere bedeutung
weil für sehen die das heißt schön jetzt
in bezug auf menschen die in erster
linie wenn ihr partner ist tatsächlich
auch der bruch der erste test sekunden
wie schmeckt der wein aber auch na ja
oder ja drin ist dem tatsächlich gehört
und wenn es denn ein längeres gespräch
bis bis zur filme ist der charakter der
inhalt von gesprächen oder aus holz
wurden denn schön fängt denim studenten
also jetzt war ich vor mit der
alexandria gerät mit mir auch schwer
sagt alexandra burke wirst du sie
beschrieben das ganze wie corona zieht
die stadt so dass wir alleine das mir
denen zusätzlicher faktor zum chöre und
zum glück sind
ich spüre also dafür dass im halo saga
oder beim konnten die relativ viel denn
schon für die personen und das entfällt
jetzt ja ich weiß dass die größe
wie wirst du dich beziehen aber schreibe
ja ich denke ich würde mal sowie die
österliche faktoren wie ich bin sagt
erschienen die sich blogger von bruno
auge und da würde ziemlich wollte mal
wahrscheinlich daran schuld dass ich
mich nur als völlig übergewichtig mit
kurven als ich selber show würde althaus
beschrieben dass ich nicht übergewichtig
wehmut
es gibt den produktiven betrieb entweder
nur glaubt sie
die teckstädter also ziehen andere
betriebe herrscht und ihr zeugnis von
dem ja der rest hat die aussicht
gestellt ist übrig will sie nicht
vorstellig mir eine übergewichtige
menschen
es hat auf dauer mit dem arthur viele
dass man den leuten unrecht tut mit dem
hat mit dem schlepper und reiter mit dem
mittel
der weg vom präparator hat das dass du
bist raus strecken und das töten und dem
entsprechenden tag strengte vision die
menge ich wünsche mir ali wäre das biz
linda richter so träge und haben wenig
fokussiert hof auf sehr problematisch
wäre ich einfach gerne ausdruck
eigentlich sind sie auch schön wenn wir
das kann ja sehr positiv
[Applaus]
schönheit ist ja ne davis wo man
geschenkt bekommt und dann hat sondern
unsere gesellschaft ist gut dass vieles
dafür kann mache ich was mache und mein
wissen wie es den menschen goldreport
collect hanspeter bäni vorbereitet für
den dokfilm mein körper mein werk
menschen wohl ganz vieles machen für
ihren körper gepumpt trainiert und
informel
[Musik]
miguel birgit fünf jahren
die lehrerschaft für möchtegern ja aber
ich mache sich recht wohl fühlen so
glücklich bin
[Musik]
beim 21 jährigen drehte sich damals
alles ums bodybuilding
er hatte zahlreiche fitness abos und
trainierte täglich birgit war auf dem
besten weg karriere zu machen in diesem
sport so da im zimmer hannes bild vor
der schweizermeisterschaft verletzt die
herbstmeisterschaft und schweizer
meisterschaft im junioren bodybuilding
gunnar es ist mein erster wettkampf sie
und brachte erfolg für mich sie bier
gibt's damalige freundin war ebenfalls
bodybuilderin auch sie nahm an
wettkämpfen teil
heute ist bei miguel birgel fast alles
anders sein einstiges leben scheint weit
weg zu sein
auch hatte eine andere freundin minute
alleine vor die mit texten ist los und
er beklagt hat dass der lifestyle nehmen
so verfolgt nämlich dass es auch klappt
es das hat mir abgestellt motivation hat
gefällt und neue weggeschlagen
aber jetzt ist es schön eine klasse idee
sind erlaubt täglich noch sich also ich
meine wir hatten nur eine wichtig ist
der grimme aber sixbreak ist immer so
wichtig so steht ja da ein
wohlstandsbauch umkreis experten sagen
dass der fokus neben fitness ist
begriffsgeschichte hört sich an wie die
banalität des großen drucks anstatt ins
training stecker seine energie jetzt
halt in sein malergeschäft
dem verpassten cut paste magazine europa
sehr gut gemacht
sein leben sei schon sehr anders als
früher sagt er
vor allem etwas haben gewonnen freiheit
ja im fitnessraum ist fast immer mehr
sagen immer das machen sie es am besten
ist aber das hätte den trend sogar
vorgeschrieben und so eine indirekte
kann unabhängig sie habe ein bisschen
strikter plan verfolge alles anders da
mbabi auch er war vor fünf jahren
beinahe täglich im fitnesscenter
anzutreffen wie wichtig ich eigentlich
der körper crew dritte und der junge ja
sich dank zu tag ich das noch sehr
wichtige auskurieren will mit juristen
gegen sunderland mit amanda möglichst
bald wieder sicher da dieser konkurrenz
die tunnel und natürlich habe der frau
wird man sehr gut auch viele tv sind wir
zu tag sei das ganze szene und man
weitermachen schlagstock der frau
insgesamt scheiße die maria sie
ernährung und fitness waren die
zentralen themen im leben des ehemaligen
fußballer stamm bene
[Musik]
selbst bei ferien im ausland überließ er
nichts dem zufall
[Musik]
nur der tasche nur für schumi also ich
kann wirklich liebt die dosis also bis
zu gut denn haben wir doch warum dann
später doch was auch johann findet
leider nicht immer alles wunder ich sein
werk auf nummer sicher immer irgendwie
für mich alles ich finde dass ich mein
körper optimal versorgen an ernährungs
und fitness plänen falte er damals in
seinem kinderzimmer stundenlang nicht
nur für sich mit wähler über 100 liter
dem symbol versuchen so gut wie möglich
zahl von mineral fonic alexandra stan
bene im sommer 2020
er hat seinen traum in einem so sollen
schlieren verwirklicht
für den laien ein banaler keller mit
fitnessgeräten für ihn weit mehr
[Musik]
stützpunkt sogenannten underground the
moment der hand die möglichkeit
persönliche atmosphäre mit dem lied
eigentlich zahlen und ich bin so wird
eigentlich als training und vorbereiter
zum nach dem italiener folge aber wieder
ganz super super schöner behrami eine
seiner rund 100 kunden dir persönlich
coacht start super
okay wir haben unzählige 70 prozent
seiner kunden seien leute die abnehmen
und muskeln aufbauen wollen
beleg dafür ist die sogenannte
transformations- wand
dreieinhalb tausend franken hat bayrami
für drei monate fitness coaching bezahlt
für den 23 jährigen ging die rechnung
auf
lieblich sind immer angebote und
gesamtpaket hat einfach für mich im los
schwierigste und mit sportkollegen gut
oder sogar bestimmen sowie der letzte
xiii und mittelwelle bin jetzt ein paar
stunden die bayrami sind die beste
werbung fürs tam bene und sein fitness
konzept machbar aber nicht einfach soll
es bei ihn sein
scott moore somit wähler und disziplin
also dass der fall darum ist natürlich
ein stück der körper spiegelbild vom
charakter marie natürlich schon mit
termin also dass sie mit schweinekopf
liebe liebe liebe liebe rein physische
und psychische veränderung das
fasziniert an bene nach wie vor ein
gutes körpergefühl bedeutet schönheits
und befriedige davon kann ich jetzt
leben wir fünf jahre hatte mich schon im
zimmer gibt findet wenig million kleine
büros 7
und dazu muss das natürlich so lustig
sie jetzt noch fünf jahre die
lithographie dann sagen fakten die
verletzte verdienen geld ohne das muss
schaaf bei ihm sinnvoller macht dass er
gerne macht sowie flexibel 10
weiterhin wurde und noch mehr erreichen
dass ein vierter fahren
stamm wenes zukunftsvision mehr fitness
center eine koch linie und am liebsten
noch mit 80 in seinem underground
anzutreffen
die gebirge sieht fitnesscenter nur noch
von innen wenn er einen maler auftrag
hat für einen ehemaligen schweizer
meister im bodybuilding erstaunlich dass
hunger dazu
vor fünf jahren ging sie in die küche an
das zu und her macht jetzt der 120 gramm
hopfen flug durchs proteinpulver waren
die durch pele hat das eigentlich gute
geschmack also so verstehe ich einfach
nicht fähig tausend stimmen so jahr und
dann nehme ich da noch zehn blöcke
womit auch sehr wichtig und ich mir sehr
viel zu spät dass das essen besuchen die
fed umbruch spezia - vitamintabletten
dass proteine ja das war einmal
putin als käme ich glaub da ja schon
längst abgelaufen
17 2008
leider wie eine unabhängig ob es in die
droge dazu nicht
das ist viel zu lang
wo im endeffekt noch einmal neun monate
pausiert und mit hilfe von den muskeln
sowieso wenn dann haben wir proteine die
blaue der woche jetzt kann man es sich
einfach
[Musik]
einst übergewichtig dann bodybuilder
bürger hat mit seinem körper schon
einiges durchgemacht und dabei auch
etwas gelernt
und ich finde man muss sich vorher
gesunde basis muss man sich selber schön
finden
das war mit sicherheit
[Musik]
reporter spezial mehr gefragt was machen
wir eigentlich alles für ihre schönheit
besuch sehr und macht sie zum schluss
aber wirklich glücklich und es ist ja
auch wenn wir nur geld teenager in der
schweiz also ab 12 bis 16 vereine sehr
gut zwei drittel show sie sind entweder
als dick oder zu dünn aus aigen findet
ihr schon sie müssten bis machen für
ihre sehe und ich bedauere jetzt in dem
rund um ski zu fahren sehr gewöhnliche m
s reifen meist überschüsse gerät wird
nämlich edf maske und das darin dass ich
die wiener hunziker shao 40 knapp 2 oder
und die wiener du hesch zum thema
aussehen ganz vieles zeigen
aber damit muss richtig könnte unsere
alte mäßig skulptur mehrere standbeine
die wiener hunziker noch für ihre
schönheitsideal alexander es fast
ruiniert erfolgte frisch dass sie zum
beispiel zum jetzigen zeitpunkt nicht
schwanger werden
was hast du ausgemacht letzten jahr mit
die ganze perfektioniert zum internet
ist erschwert und das geschafft haben
und ich irgendwann kalaschnikows tour
machen heute ein kraftsportler
blickwechsel zuflüssen der übergang sie
und plötzlich ein effektvoller tag
gefunden
irgendwelche ist sehr ins griffe dass
man auch ohne schrauben anziehen und
perfektionieren wieder das vor sich
ja ich bin oft in kontakt kommen zwei
bodybuilderin damals geschminkt und
frisiert und vielen jahren können und da
bin ich ganz interessiert sie wie sie
das geschafft haben das arbeitsgerät sie
will dass ich das machen aber gesteht
sie dass ich so weit also das ist mein
körper so fest aber definiert das
muskelfaserriss und da hat mir die
das sagt und habe mich dann wirklich
interessiert über noch klasse und im
irak kam auch für mich nicht mit dem
ziel dass ich gegangen sondern kapazität
will es limit wirklich spüren wo er kann
im körper triebe wie heißt du wählen sie
was ich diese ideal für die linie also
perfekt
ich empfand einmal unbedingt als
fertiges bild sind sie klar ich habe
muskulöse sich aber jetzt muss kratos
als muskelfaserriss ec2 putin zum
beispiel aber es ist mixa werde logitech
bringe ich mein fett wert aber was
einfach so aus eigener kraft ohne
hilfsmittel will im bodybuilding ist es
bekannt dass die meiste halt wirklich
mit der zusatzstoff schaffen und das
dann alles erreicht und musste ich das
sehe ich wirklich und natürlich absolute
maximum ist wirklich absolut niedrigem
fettanteil und viel muskelmasse und die
beschleunigung konnte ist also so etwas
wie definiert sich ja und das wenn du
jetzt die bilder alu rex features schön
wenn ich jetzt plötzlich zurück gegeben
und sie sagen ich wirklich nicht aus wie
nichts dort so ausgesehen im spiegel
ok ich komme ich anders ich habe jetzt
aber und eine jetzt bild rolle und ist
so viel 12 und darum bin ich froh dass
sie mich entschieden ist er wieder
zurück obwohl sehr sehr schwierig ist
und stelle eine stunde moment so gut
merkte dass ich dass mein körper mir
zeigt hat das ist eine periode
ausblieben schönen effekt und sie nicht
die immer noch nicht ob sie beschwerde
büros folgekosten probiert es ist immer
lustig
hilft das alles so schlimme sachen wo
sich dann so summierten sich im moment
ich muss aus gesundheitlichen und faire
steht bevor wir es so viel investiert
dass wir so einen perfekten körper zum 1
das muss extrem schwierig sie bauen sind
wahnsinnig schwierig also immer noch
dass ich es bilder so in brand im kopf
so extrem darüber ja allgemein mal
verwandelt sich ganz schwierig zum dann
nicht wieder sagen jetzt wieder mich
strikt und kalorienhaltige referierte so
einfach wie eben noch blanca und hoffe
dass sich alles wieder normalisiert
haben mit dem hormon allem das ist der
preis für das hoffentlich ohne den
buchungen ja ganze ist also ich bin
wirklich tragen schaffe immer mehr weg
zu weniger verbissen sie und mein körper
braucht tatsache ich will sie ist
und obwohl er ist sowohl die weniger
sport und ich glaube darum durch die
extreme die maßnahme dass das dass der
körper check politische vita safe und
dass alles wieder so passiert ist und
warum sie unbedingt zu dem sie viel
weniger sport machen ja wieviel
liquidität 60 wo eigentlich für den
raubbau betrieben für die gesundheit
ich glaube extrem viel und ich glaube so
extrem wichtig dass man über systeme red
und das ausspricht was er vor ort mit
sich bringt will ich habe vor allem die
junge wurde vor der wm wo sich unser
liveticker
ich habe genau deine müssen oder eben
wirklich sagen wie gefährlich das ist
dass man einfach lieber normal blieb tim
gute mittel muss und nicht noch deine
instagram oder haftungen ganze social
media noch deine liebe zeigen
mit dem perfekten schuss schnell sich
wirklich entlastet hat vorher und also
ich meine politik mache ganze sache und
dann die arbeit der wiener gasse und das
gefühl wenn wir das blog das ist normal
ist realität also muss ich es nicht
es ist absolut nicht das einmal vor
rädern peter gaugg oder wird es der
einzige seite sieht die stimme die ganze
sache wie ich bin eigentlich glücklich
heißt das neue stück will sagen gutes
rennen machen und dann werden wir schon
glücklich stellen akzeptiert als
übertrieben mir ist total mit dem was
wir alles machen für riesen kripo für
die schönheit oder sind weitaus
behauptet eine schule her der bundesrat
wie selber irgendwie trend mache für
ihre schönheit gespannt ob ich mein ich
gerne kommentarspalten
aber ein punkt zwischen du jetzt
sozusagen eine rote punkt zum weg zur
besserung kann oft dreckig eine pci
controller also dreck in die hand
langsam füllt sich langsam
das trainingspensum reduziert sich gegen
schluss setzte drei bis vier mal die
woche trainieren immer vor dem herrn von
guttenberg zu der besserung aber noch
nicht die motive nicht ganz aber das
kommt
mache ganz viele specials im körper aber
es gibt andere sachen die passieren zum
beispiel eltern oder kann unter gebe mir
so viel geld aus um die spuren zu jürgen
rose oder vom hof aber über anti falten
creme bis zu ganz viel
schönheitschirurgischen eingriff ist
schönheit wirkliches privileg für die
jugend später lernen rätsel frau keine
wo das total anders sieht und die
richter jetzt gehen wenn wir doch eltern
hält man das so ist ist doch so lief
nicht ob ich mich schön
nein das kann ich zeigen kann mir
veränderung fühlt sowie carmen meyer
jahrgang 1951 bei einem fotoshooting in
zürich ich glaube mit der mauer und der
briefkasten weg besteht das ist auch der
[Musik]
seit sie sich erinnern kann haben
aussehen und styling eine wichtigkeit in
ihrem leben
die mutter eine italienerin habe das
schönste baby aus ihr machen wollen aber
schon als kleine habe sie nicht alles
akzeptiert immer mehr innerer das in
italia hat mir meine tante essbar schuhe
kauft und dann hätte er die schuhe und
ich wage mich so genau erinnern und wie
sie schon gar nicht und dann weiß ich
weiß dass man einfach durch hupen ist
das hamit welle und dann ist dir dank
einer seinen tisch sie will sie einmal
höfendorf mehr hat sie mehr die
schubkraft mariella qual machen nix ist
gesichert
mit 20 war die kauffrau dann
kosmetikerin mit eigenem geschäft mit 55
wurde sie in den bündner bergen entdeckt
als model
seither ist sie als so genanntes gray
model international gefragt london
bologna zürich in der branche spricht
man von diversity nicht nur vom auto her
sondern einfach allgemein modus vor
verschiedenen herkunft steht eine
hutfarbe verschiedenen kleidergröße
verschiedenes alter ich fand es schön
wenn das noch nie haben das wird branche
ist da ist darum steht eigentlich schon
sichtbar und der schweiz ist noch nichts
sagt
bei den proportionen werden allerdings
keine kompromisse gemacht die müssen
stimmen
[Musik]
die schönheit macht glücklich man kann
doch schönheit mit allen sinnen erfassen
es macht doch glücklich wenn die wenn
das schönste bild sehen oder schöne
architektur ziehen und schöneren gesehen
oder schöne ort in das kanalnetz schöner
schmuck kann oder eine begebenheit hat
doch mit sogar frauen wichtig jetzt im
raum
die beiden anderen am tisch die haben
wir schon kennen gelernt als model
entdeckt lauftreff die großen laufstege
italienischen modemetropole wohnt
wunderbaren zürich eines tolles
geschafft ganz viel niedriger bedienen
ich habe jetzt das sei aber das ist mir
jetzt nicht einfach wenn der bulle ist
haben auch sehr sehr sehr viel geschafft
für das ist nicht einfach nur da und ich
bin ich da und ich gucke mir gut und ich
finde das schön sie schauen nicht
selbstverständlich aber es wäre genau
gleich gar ein wenig bin wenn ich
irgendwo ganz anders trainer irgendwo in
ein kaff irgendwo es künftig selber aber
woher und das selbstbewusst dass du
eigentlich sowie nicht das spüre ich das
körperlich be ok so wenig bringen
die wurden ja also ich weiß nicht ob das
schön ist wie sie haben mir mehr sorgen
hat auch mitwisser hat eine tolle frisur
kann man dann einfach entspannt sie wie
man ist dass das ist das was für mich
zählt china ist dass wir also jetzt am
tag sex immer zählen reines sie mit sich
selber was ist das geschenk und was löst
germanisierung ist ein eleganter und
merke ich kann das ganz kurz es ist
sofort lässt also man hat nichts gefühlt
gesteht natürlich dass du gut bist
natürlich elegant die erschienen
das war magisch mit ihm
und ich denke das ist wirklich wo die
uridee haifa stark sie du musst da muss
doch mit lose was der andere
du musst doch nicht so sehr wie die
anderen sondern sie wie du wie du dich
wohl fühlst du dich wohl fühlst den
besuch ein glücklicher mensch wie auch
immer du bist doch es ist nicht so dass
man sich selber interessiert
nein danke
und das wird vom umfeld leider stück
wird mit definierten mitbeeinflusst und
das ist nicht einfach
grund sei dass herd das zieht doch
selber dass das ist die einfache zum
schluss gekommen ist dass du hast doch
nichts gleiche selbstbewusste entwickeln
waren wir immer nur auf die rundfahrt
wird dass du nicht okay ich war wohl
einfach irgendeinen in russisch und ich
muss mir das jetzt natürlich gewachsen
ich bin eine 40
aber ich hoffe mir das jetzt neu das
selbstbewusste hätte mir das gespräch
von 1 23 ort führt hätte ich mir ganz
österreich
immer wieder aber ich muss die da jetzt
viele sprache ich brauche das nicht
nachvollziehen wie es für mich schwierig
im fitnesscenter zeit wurden die haare
wenn es voll werden
bekanntlich
wahrscheinlich sei wenn es diese regel
du musst dich nicht verstecken sich
nicht darüber einig doch in waltrop
setzte ich mich stören die helfer stellt
sie baut doch nicht verstecken
doch kein rundum habe mir zu produkt wie
nicht bekannt doch da er mir geht das
teilte macy's diffus aus manager etwas
mit alexandra zur sache geht hier doch
nicht denken das geht mir sicherlich
denken aber die haben das überhaupt
und das sei wenig sprach di sigrid pook
sich doch leider größen sind eigentliche
problem sondern ist umgang mit menschen
wo vier grad anders sind oder anders
ausgesehen
weg von der fixierung auf der oberfläche
macht mir mut schöner aber viele
glückliche
schönheit ist das glück fehlen
wo zeigt wie viel das juni in florenz
auf sich nehmen um sich möglichst
optimal präsentieren und wie wichtig für
die snb einen kilometer vom band
abonniere einfach diesen kanal aktiviere
glocker und dem verbessert und mehr
firmen für sind pressen und mit händels